It is allowed to cool quickly and we proceed to
hopefully it will be as fast as possible,
fulfilling
the truth, we are very happy to
inaugurate this offering of the dead in La
Bonita, which is located on
Hayel street. In all the stores in La Bonita they
make this offering of the dead that  not
only preserve our traditions
but also show all
visitors and all
mexican and non-mexican buyers the importance
of this holiday the day of the dead
commemorates all our ancestors
who have passed away as we say
and november 2 is when  we celebrate
this beautiful event
movies like coco and some other
movies have made
the day of the dead very popular in the world and that is why
we come here to celebrate it and also to
show the bread of the dead the bread of the
dead is one more sample of our
gastronomy  of our pastry
our artisans because they are not
only bakers but they are artisans
because in each piece
the sample of life and  death and the
flavor of sugar, sesame seeds and the
different ways of making pan de
muerto make mexico project itself in
the world as a cultural power and
that shows in our traditions how they
are a rich mixture of the spanish world of
the colony and the  indigenous world in a
very beautiful syncretism on the day of the
dead we are going to have an altar
for the dead from the consulate on November 2, 1 and
2 at the winchester cultural center
where we are going to make
our own altar community groups
and others are going to install  their own
altars and for me a pleasant surprise there are
many events in the city on the
day of the dead so I invite
people to participate in the one they
like the most the circular shape of the bread
represents the cycle of life and the death
of being
the little ball  in the middle is the skull and the
lines are the bones with which
we are formed